bonjour alors la manifestation n'est
toujours pas parti pour le moment
non mais ça semble être le cas à
l'instant même où je vous parle puisque
effectivement les manifestants étaient
rassemblés sur cette place du palais
royal depuis de longues minutes
maintenant il ya un mouvement qui est en
train de s'amorcer vous allez pouvoir
voir sur ces images avec des
manifestants qui sont en train de
prendre la route
a priori en direction du pont des arts
qui est le point d'arrivée de cette
manifestation on rappelle que le préfet
de police de paris avait interdit un
tracé qui avait été déposée initialement
par les organisateurs pour cette marche
des pouvoirs comme allait présenter
l'idée c'était donc de rejoindre un
certain nombre de lieux symboliques
telles que l'assemblée nationale
matignon ou encore l'arc de triomphe
rien de tout ça pour aujourd'hui mais
donc possiblement cette marche jusqu'au
pont des arts qui n'est finalement pas
très loin de l'endroit où nous sommes
alors vous l'avez dit c'est une marche
contre la loi sécurité globale n'est pas
seulement il ya également les
revendications historiques v gilet jaune
davantage de justice sociale de justice
fiscale mais également des
revendications autour des consultations
citoyennes et puis au delà du gilet
jaune il y à un nouveau symbole de
ralliement pour les manifestants en ce
samedi c'est un parapluie arc en ciel
vous le voyez peut-être sur certaines
des images ici c'est un parapluie qui
fait référence à une manifestante qui a
été interpellé la semaine dernière lors
de la manifestation parisienne elle
était soupçonnée par les forces de
l'ordre d'être une des meneuses du black
blocks propose d'écouter quelques
manifestants justement sur ce parapluie
symbolique on les écoute ta aujourd'hui
et le le petit signe de ralliement
c'était le parapluies multicolores par
rapport à moon qui a été mise en garde à
vue on veut montrer qu'on est pacifiste
toujours un c'est toujours pareil et
qu'on est unie face à cette répression
le motif d'interpellation c'est quand
même un sketch dire que c'est une
dangereuse menace des dagues log
d'ailleurs sur bfm j'entends qu'elle
posséder une arme de catégorie a c'est
une arme de guerre une arme de catégorie
là je sais pas si j des conneries un
avocat qui est parmi nous c'est bien une
arme de guerre catégorie 1 c'est ça bon
bref faut arrêter le sketch pour bfm dit
les infos faut étayer quand même - bfm
avec monsieur dry qu'il paye les
musiciens faut essayer quand même les
propos donc voilà et moi je lâche et le
soutien qu'on a décidé que maintenant ça
c'était une arme de catégorie 1 alors
que c'est des gens qui sont
juste pour égayer la manip voilà donc
pour les propos de ces manifestants
voyez les forces de l'ordre qui nous
demandent de suivre le mouvement puisque
vous allez voir sur ces images
ils sont en train de regagner la place
du palais royal où étaient présents les
manifestants ils vont donc accompagner
cette manifestation il faut dire qu'il y
a une fois encore un important
dispositif de sécurité qui a été déployé
ici avec notamment des contrôles pour
les manifestants lorsqu'ils souhaitent
arriver sur cette place du palais royal
merci à thomas pour toutes ces
précisions